CHRIS BAILEY: Hi, everyone.
Thanks for joining.
We're excited to
talk to you today
about the deskless
workforce and how
you can digitize and streamline
their work without writing
a line of code.
We'll talk about who the
deskless workforce is,
what are the challenges
they're facing,
and how organizations
can use AppSheet
apps to solve those challenges
and boost productivity.
We'll walk through
several great examples
of what these apps look like
and how they are actually
being used in the field.
Now, before we
jump in, we'd like
to give a quick
introduction to who we are.
My name is Chris Bailey.
I'm a product marketing manager
on the Google AppSheet team
and was actually with AppSheet
before it was acquired
by Google in January this year.
And I'm very excited to be
joined by Johnny Hacking, who
is the Director of IT at BHI.
Johnny, would you like to
introduce yourself and maybe
give a little background
about BHI as well?
JOHNNY HACKING: Awesome.
Thanks Chris.
Hi, I'm Johnny Hacking.
And I'm the IT
Director here at BHI
and have been for
the past three years.
And I've been in the IT
field for over 15 years.
Now BHI is a turnkey
general contractor
that began as an
electrical contractor
and has grown into a company
that serves a civil, pipeline,
communication, electrical, and
renewable energy industries
across the United States.
CHRIS BAILEY: Now,
we've already mentioned
AppSheet a couple times.
And I realize that many people
are just learning about it.
So I wanted to start off by
giving a quick introduction
and overview to
what AppSheet is.
AppSheet is a no code
application development
platform that enables
anyone to create apps fast.
At a high level, it's
a simple process.
First, you connect your data.
AppSheet can connect to a
wide variety of data sources,
including Excel files,
Google Sheets, cloud SQL,
and on-premise databases.
Then you can customize your
app within the AppSheet editor,
and create and adjust views,
workflows, notifications,
and more.
Finally, you can deploy
your applications out
to both mobile and
desktop devices.
And AppSheet does
an excellent job
of being responsive and working
on all of these devices.
So while AppSheet integrates
with a wide variety
of software, we found that
it is particularly powerful
when combined with G Suite.
The two products work
together in many ways.
You can store app data
and content on drive.
You can build an app
directly on top of Sheets,
and create, read, update,
and delete Sheets data
from the app.
You can open up Google
Meet, use Docs as templates,
create and update
calendar invites,
and extend your
forms functionality.
There's a lot of goodness
that comes from using the two
platforms together.
And I definitely
recommend exploring
how you can use them to solve
your business challenges.
So that's a high level
overview of what AppSheet is.
Now we want to shift
the topic and focus more
on the deskless
workforce and the ways
we can utilize AppSheet
to enable those teams.
80% of the global
workforce is deskless.
These are people
working in the field
and on the floor who have
to get up and move around,
and don't spend the majority of
their time next to a computer.
Think of field technicians,
construction workers,
sales representatives, doctors,
nurses, event managers,
manufacturing specialists,
just to name a few.
More and more, we're seeing
deskless workers looking
to technology to find ways
to improve productivity
and efficiency.
And these challenges
they are facing
are different from those
faced by desk workers.
For example, while it may be
very easy for someone sitting
at a desk to open up a new
Sheet, write up an invoice,
adjust margins and
formatting, that
can be much more difficult for
someone who's in the field,
as they may not have
a computer and they
may be on their
mobile phone or tablet
where it's just trickier
to format a document
and perform actions like that.
Now BHI's deskless
workers have been
using AppSheet in some
really interesting ways.
So I actually want to
pass it over to Johnny
to talk about those
challenges they were facing,
and how they use
AppSheet to solve them.
JOHNNY HACKING: Awesome, thanks.
So a challenge we
faced was we were
required to submit
multiple inspection
forms on a daily basis
for one of our projects.
And current processes
just didn't work.
It was to fill out paper forms
in the field, and then later,
inputting that data to
send off from a computer
either at a hotel, job
trailer, or other location.
This needed to be done
for all inspections
that day, which were
multiple, sometimes 30 plus.
And we didn't have the manpower
to meet these requirements.
For this project, management
looked to IT for a solution.
Because hiring more people
would put the project's success
in jeopardy.
The current process
was not working.
Forms and spreadsheets
brought challenges
of managing data and workflows
across multiple jobs.
Developers can be costly.
And external solutions are
inflexible because it's never
just one external solution.
You know, we have multiple
divisions here at BHI,
and they all have
different needs.
Now BHI had just
migrated to G Suite
and was having great success
with the collaboration
it brought.
And that's when we found that
AppSheet on top of G Suite
gave us the ability
to take full advantage
of these digital platforms.
It gave us the offline
capability in an actual app,
and was easy for our
users in the field
that are in very different
working conditions.
AppSheet works seamless
with Google Sheets and Docs,
making it easy to push out
applications fast and simple.
Actually, one of the apps in
the demo you will see later,
we made in a matter of hours
on a job site in a job trailer.
Customization of AppSheet
has helped us save money
because we are custom making
apps for specific jobs
that sometimes only get
used once for a project.
One thing to note is
that it isn't just IT
that is developing these apps,
but people from multiple teams
that help make them better
because a lot of the times,
they understand the
needs of their project
better than we do.
IT is just brought
in as a final step
to review the app
before it goes live.
Since using AppSheet, I've
been told multiple times
on job sites how much
they love the apps,
and to keep them
coming because they're
making their job a lot easier.
Now AppSheet has solved
a lot of our problems
and transformed the way
we work as a company.
Its ease of use allows
for my small team
to deploy apps that
meet the requirements
of multiple disciplines rapidly.
Forms that are
required on every job
are now digital and
filled out on the fly,
with all the data being
stored in Google Drive.
Apps aren't just forms,
though, but something
that is tailored for each job.
We have ones that are used
across the entire company,
and others specific to projects
because of the information
gathered and reported
in real time.
This has cut costs by
reducing our overall IT
budget by 10%, when we normally
paid that to other third party
softwares.
And an example is some quality
inspections on electrical work
was taking up to two hours
to do one inspection.
By the time everything
was filled out
and inputted into
a PDF, combined
with pictures taken
onsite, and emailed
to the client on a daily
basis from a computer
back in the office.
Not only did our apps allow
this to happen in the field,
but they also cut down these
inspection forms from two hours
to six minutes.
This was a solution
to our challenge
in the previous slide.
The result was money
saved and we're
able to meet the
job requirements.
AppSheet has also
given us more time.
With two of our AppSheet
apps, from one department
completely freed up
20 to 30 hours a week.
This time was generally spent
on printing and scanning
forms to manually inputting
data into a spreadsheet
so that it could be analyzed.
Now our workflows do this
in a matter of minutes.
We are now making decisions
on data that's happening now,
versus what happened
two weeks ago.
The best part about
this is our employees
are coming up with
new, innovative ways
we can use AppSheet, which isn't
happening in conference rooms,
but across construction
sites all over the country.
CHRIS BAILEY: Awesome.
Now Johnny, if it's OK,
let's actually walk through
some of the apps you've
created with your team and talk
about how they've
been beneficial
for the mobile workers.
JOHNNY HACKING: So this is
our company dashboard app.
It's basically, we
call it BHI Relay.
And it's a bunch
of apps you can see
that we've created for
a lot of use cases,
such as equipment rentals, time
tracking, PTO, and HR forms.
With the company being
as diverse as it is,
it's an easy one
stop shop for people
to find what they need,
regardless of their department.
CHRIS BAILEY: Great.
Now let's open up a
couple of these apps
and walk through how
they're actually being used.
So let's click on
Safety apps demo,
which will open up another
menu of safety specific apps.
And let's look at
the Near Miss Report.
JOHNNY HACKING: Awesome.
So yeah, this is
filled out whenever
there's an incident that
almost occurs on a job site
or in an office building,
anything like that.
So if it were to happen
and I was an employee,
I could either notify
my foreman or myself.
If I was in that position,
I could come to here.
And first off, the view
you're going to see
is all the Near Miss forms
that I filled out in the past.
Or if I was a
foreman, and I would
be able to see ones
that I have filled out
or ones that have been
filled out for the employees
that I'm over.
And if once I open this
up, I'm right here.
In the bottom right,
there's a plus.
And let's say I need to
fill out a Near Miss.
I'm going to hit
that plus, which
is going to bring us to the
form and start walking us
through here.
Fill out our incident location,
where this happened out
in the building, janitor
closet, parking lot, whatever.
And then right here in the Near
Miss, you get to a section.
We've had times like this.
As a construction company,
we do work for other people.
And sometimes, the
companies we do
work for, they require
us to use their forms.
Well we want people,
our employees,
to use the app because it's
very important for what we do.
But at the same
time, we don't want
to be requiring our
employees to fill out
three or four
different type of forms
and wasting all that time when
they can be doing other things.
And so we made it easy for them
to select the picture item.
And then they could
click on the picture icon
and actually take a picture of
the Near Miss they filled out.
CHRIS BAILEY: And I'll
interject here, and just
say that when you
select picture,
and you're on a mobile
device, it will just open up
the camera right there
so that you can actually
take a picture of the form
and save it down to your app.
JOHNNY HACKING: And we also
created that for a file.
Because on some
jobs, someone else
has filled out the Near
Miss for that other company,
and then e-mailed us a PDF copy.
Well it's given us a way there
that we can click on File,
click on that icon, and browse
to a PDF or some other document
on the computer and
upload it as well.
But let's say for this instance,
sometimes, we don't have those.
We can click NA.
And then that is
going to present us
with the rest of the
information that we
need to fill out in order to
complete the Near Miss form.
And so, we're just going to
kind of go down and fill out
some of the data,
answer the questions.
And one thing I
really like here,
and which is huge with
all our safety apps,
is sometimes, it's nice to be
able to require the information
that needs to be filled out.
CHRIS BAILEY: Yeah, so
essentially, everything
with a star is required.
And if you try to move
on to the next step
without filling those
out, you'll get an error.
And you can also set
additional parameters
on those requirements
like, specifying
that it has to be an email or a
number or something like that.
JOHNNY HACKING: And then
we're going to get down here
with the employee signature.
Just so you know that if you are
on a tablet or a smart device,
and you click on that,
you'll be able to just draw
with your finger or
a stylus or whatever,
and actually capture people's
real life signatures.
And then at the very bottom,
you can fill in an email address
if, for some reason,
you need it to email
a copy of this Near Miss to that
person for reporting purposes.
You fill that in.
Once it saves,
AppSheet has a workflow
that combines this information,
puts it into a PDF,
and emails it off
to that person.
Now that we've hit
Save, you can see all
that it's been added with
the other Near Misses that
have been filled out.
And it's right here.
And we have done our job.
CHRIS BAILEY: Now,
there's one more app
that I think is really clever
that we want to show you.
The Time Entry app.
JOHNNY HACKING:
So yeah, this app
is really interesting because
COVID had just happened.
And we needed to
create something
that would meet all
the requirements
of social distancing and not
to touch as many surfaces
as possible as we could
for this job site.
And to keep track
of time, people
would just click on a
tablet and punch it in.
Well, not with this case.
We created a solution
so we didn't have to.
On Setup here, each employee
will be in the list.
And we'd add employees.
And we'd give everyone a
bar code that was a sticker.
And we'd put that
underneath their hardhat.
From there, every day, the
person in charge of time
would click on Check In.
And what that would
do is it would open up
the scanned section.
And if you were on a tablet,
it would open up the camera
itself.
And it would just stay
open all the time.
What would happen is when
a bar code is filled in,
or you hold their hardhat,
the bar code sticker,
the camera will recognize
that, fill in the bar code.
It will save it,
and automatically
go to the next one.
And it will just keep doing this
all day until that person would
come back and get the tablet, at
which everyone has been clocked
in for the day, not having to
touch the iPad or the tablet
or anything.
CHRIS BAILEY: At
this point, you're
likely curious to see what
these applications look
like on the back end.
So I'm going to open
up the AppSheet editor
and show you what it looks like.
So let's look at the Time Entry
app that Johnny just showed us
and see what it looks
like behind the scenes.
Now all of that apps data is
hosted in this Google Sheet.
It has two tabs, the
first with a simple table
that will update as
people clock in and out,
and the second with the
employees emails and associated
bar codes.
To create an app, all you'd
have to do to get started
is to pull up AppSheet
and connect it
to a spreadsheet like this.
So let's see what it looks
like in the App editor.
This is the AppSheet editor.
Over here on the right, you can
see a live preview of the app.
And you can switch
to different views,
whether you want to see phone,
tablet, or desktop views.
On the far left, we have the
main menu of Edit Options.
The key ones you need to know
when you're getting started
are Info, which gives
high level information
about your app, Data, which
lets you build and update
your tables, columns, and
sizes, UX, where you can adjust
the look and feel of
the app, and Behavior,
where you can set up actions,
workflows, and reports.
Let me highlight a few
key features of this app.
So when we go to Data Tables
in this time tracker app,
we can see that the same
tables in the spreadsheet
are also listed out here.
Timesheet and Setup.
When we select View Columns,
we see that all the columns
were added as well.
There's also some
additional columns
that have been created to
add functionality to the app.
And several of them,
if we look here,
include formulas that
we've added to help
run the logic of the app.
Next, if you wanted to adjust
the look and feel of the app,
you can go to UX Brand
and easily change your app
to light mode or
dark mode, and adjust
your colors, which you
can see being updated
in the live preview here.
Now let's say you wanted to
have an automated report sent
to the payroll manager that
showed how long each employee
worked that day.
That report is simple to set up.
You can go to Behavior,
Reports, and select New Report.
Here, we've already created one.
So let's just open
that up to give you
an idea of what that
report can look like.
So Daily, at 8:00
PM Mountain Time,
use the Today's Timetable,
which, just so you know,
is a virtual table or slice
that we created within this app.
We don't have to set
additional conditions.
So let's leave
that section blank.
And do this.
Let's send an email
to these two addresses
with this information,
and a note
here that you can
have piped text to.
And let's also
send a text message
so that they know the
report is in their inbox.
So you update all this.
And after that, you click
Save, test the report out
once or twice, and
start using it.
Now I'm going to stop the demo
here because, unfortunately, we
don't have time to go through
every piece of this app.
But we have extensive
documentation online, as well
as a very active
AppSheet community
that can help you get
started and answer
any questions you have.
Now before we end, we
wanted to just give you
a few more ideas of
other common apps
we see customers building
for their deskless workers.
We've talked a lot about
field service and inspections
and audits.
But we also see
people using actually
for inventory management,
project management,
such as on-site budget
tracking and worker
management, human resources,
such as onboarding, training
and time sheets, and
sales and marketing,
which is especially
useful when you have
a mobile workforce that
spends a lot of time
out in the field talking
to prospects and customers.
Hopefully this
presentation has given you
some valuable information
on how you can better
enable your mobile workforce.
If you'd like to learn
more about AppSheet
or start creating apps, you can
get started at AppSheet.com.
So thank you for watching this
presentation and happy app
building.